(theme song electronic music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour,
as always, I've enjoyed
hosting these conversations
and enjoy having
conversations with my guests
on this program.
But today I'm extra excited
for this specific program
and specific topic
we'll be covering,
and also the very excited
about the guest who's joining.
So today we'll be talking about sleep,
emotional wellness and mental health,
something which I think
all of us can relate to.
And I'm honored to be able to host
Dr. Obo Addy on the podcast,
the original Dr. Addy, in a sense.
So obviously you can tell
I'm excited about this
and really grateful for
his willingness to jump in
and to be able to share
so many important tips
with all of us.
So by way of introduction,
Dr. Obo Addy is currently
a sleep physician at the
University of Michigan Health West.
He also has an appointment as
a clinical associate professor
in the departments of
medicine and psychiatry
at Michigan State University.
He's had previous positions at places
like Case Western Reserve University,
also at Emory University
School of Medicine in Atlanta.
And he's someone who
has been deeply involved
in both psychiatry and sleep
medicine for over 30 years,
so has expertise on both sides
of the house, so to speak,
and the intersection between the two.
He's a husband, he's also
a father of four children
and a grandfather of five.
And he's someone who continues
to be invested in many
different ways in the
community, through his church,
but has also done things
in the broader community,
even in his semi-retired state right now,
he's been involved in
setting up sleep clinics
in Ghana for the past several years,
and so has continued to
make sure that the expertise
that he has and what
he's been able to bring
to the community and to
different fields of medicine
continues to have impact in lives.
So I'm grateful to be
able to welcome him today.
Just as a little bit of a full circle,
I remember growing up and
watching him on a CNN interview
where he was talking about
his work and being very proud
and awe-inspired.
So it's full circle for
me to be able to host him
on my own podcast and grateful
to welcome Dr. Obo Addy
to the podcast today.
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- Thanks for being here.
And I'm just excited to be
able to move this conversation
in a lot of ways.
And this has been something that's been
in the back of my mind for a while.
Just the benefits that I've
had growing up with you
and all the insights that
you've shared with us
over the years.
So
(laughs)
That's true.
Maybe that's what peaked
my interest initially,
even though I think at the
time I was trying to evolve
in my mind and go far
away from your field,
which I was very unsuccessful at. (laughs)
At some point we have to find
that picture if you have it.
Excellent.
Well, as my listeners know,
I always like to just check in
and see how my guests are doing overall,
just with all the different
things that you're doing
in your semi-retirement with
your family responsibilities.
Even the ways that you've
helped my family out
in the last few weeks and the sleep clinic
that you're doing in Ghana,
how is everything in your own life,
especially in the midst
of the ongoing pandemic?
- Well, COVID affects everything.
It did affect the planned trips to Ghana,
but on a personal level,
one of the things I found
a little disruptive was
the most recent trip to
Ghana, actually last two,
one in April and another in July.
What you have to go
through with COVID testing
that within a two, three week period,
I had to have three COVID tests,
which are not pleasant.
So then there's one test
72 hours before the flight.
And then when you get to Ghana,
you have a rapid test at the
airport and you stay there
for the result before you
can leave the airport.
And then when you are coming back,
you have to have another COVID test.
So for me, having three COVID tests
in a two, three week period
was not very pleasant.
But to put it in perspective, I mean,
I had the understanding,
the reason for this
it's for my own health and
for the health of others.
And I think a lot of people
are going through this
where there is some
discomfort or annoyance
about some of the things
that we have to go through,
but I think we have to
be open to accepting
these inconveniences for the overall good.
So that's my personal
experience with COVID
and how to deal with.
- No, that makes a lot of sense.
And it sounds like these
weren't the painless tests,
it sounds like you'd had the deeper swabs
and all that, as well, and.
- Yes, and the very first
one that I had, I said,
it's like somebody is
trying to poke a needle
into the base of your brain.
- Oh boy. (laughs)
Wow, that is saying something
for you, as a psychiatrist,
to use that analogy, as well.
But I think you said it well, too,
in terms of just people
being willing to have
the inconveniences for their own health
and for those around them, as well.
How were things, not
to jump too far ahead,
but how were things in Ghana
when you went, as well,
in terms of people's
perspectives about COVID
and a willingness to kind of abide
by some of these practices
and things like that?
- People have been fairly accepting.
I mean, there are no overt protests.
There are people who are comfortable,
but as opposed to maybe things we see
in the Western part of the world,
people are more accepting
of what their government's
position on things is.
I think it's because of
maybe the traditional way
of things and the way things are set up,
that people look up more to
authority in a lot of ways
or to the elders.
So the president, in that
sense, is the most senior elder
for the country.
So if he said, this is good for us,
although people may not like it,
they are generally accepting
and people are wearing their masks.
I mean, there are people who
are not following the rules,
but by-and-large, people are
accepting and recognizing
that there is a problem going on,
it's a pandemic and people
want to see it control.
- Oh, that's encouraging to hear.
And it seems like with that
role with the elders, too,
there's two sides to that
because there's the earned,
there's the respect that's there,
but then it seems like it
also has to be kept, as well,
and not used in the way that
actually is harmful to people.
So there's a lot of weight
there, as well, in some ways.
- And maybe that's what has led to some
of the dictatorships in
the African continent,
that because of their respectful elders.
Yeah, some of these leaders
have abused that privilege
and we've seen dictators
there, unfortunately.
- Yeah, no, that makes a lot of sense.
And it's encouraging to hear
that things are in that,
moving in that way now, at least
in Ghana, in a lot of ways,
It actually leads to the next question.
Just thinking about your
profession as someone
in sleep medicine, as well,
because I know obviously
personally from your trajectory
and your path going into psychiatry,
there were aspects that came up initially
in terms of whether that was
favored by the government,
the types of work you're doing
and how it was looked upon
and how that shaped your own path.
So I think it would be
helpful for our listeners,
if you could share how
you got into psychiatry
and sleep medicine in the first place.
And I guess the intersection
between your personal story
and the role of the government,
as much as you're willing to share.
- Yeah.
I think God gives us different
interests and affinities
for certain things.
So I don't know that I can
pinpoint what led to my interest
in psychiatry, but there
was a very early interest
in the things of the
mind and how that works.
And I think that also
relates to my Christian faith
and background as to what God is doing
and it's not just all the things
you can measure that much.
So there was an initial
interest in psychiatry,
but in medical school in
Ghana, that was downplayed.
The idea was we have big
problems with infectious diseases
and other things.
And why would anyone want
to focus on psychiatry?
That is not that important.
So for me, the whole
thing came more to light
when I was doing my
rural service in Ghana.
And as a general medical practitioner,
you are doing everything
that one year or two years
out of medical school.
Doing everything means I was doing things
like hernia surgeries.
And one of the most satisfying was doing
emergency caesarian sections.
And to have a healthy mother
and a healthy baby afterwards.
But then what struck me
as I was running a clinic
that I was at there were
people who were coming in,
especially some of the women
from maybe abusive families
who repeatedly will be at
a clinic seeking some care,
and there was no physical
care or need at that point.
It quickly became obvious
to me that these people had
emotional problems that
nobody was dealing with.
And they were coming to
the clinic and coming
to the doctor for help.
But then, the thing that maybe
promoted more the interest
to pursue my interest
in psychiatry was this.
I knew how to handle
most medical emergencies.
I knew how to treat routine
things like the malaria.
Like I said, I could handle
emergency (indistinct).
I could handle emergency
caesarian sections.
I had no idea how to handle
any psychiatric emergencies.
So it strike me that there
was this clear need there.
And although this had been downplayed,
what my professors were saying
was not really accurate,
that there was no need,
there was a huge need.
So then that led me to follow
the interest and the affinity
that I say God had given
me to go into a field
that will help those who
are emotionally distressed
and needed help.
- Oh, that's encouraging to hear.
And so how did you take those steps
if the avenue wasn't clear in a sense,
if the precedent wasn't there also?
- Yeah. So then I did talk to,
well, he was actually an uncle by marriage
who was a psychiatrist who I looked up to.
So I asked him how one would do this.
So he did encourage me, but then he said,
well, you may have a glorified
idea of what psychiatry is.
So why don't you get a clearer idea?
So he invited me to work
with him for some time
attached to the main psychiatric
hospital in the capital,
in Accra.
And this was the old type asylum.
I mean, there were good rooms,
but then some of them were
basically being put there
just for custodial care.
And there wasn't much good treatment.
In a sense, he opened my eyes to see
maybe the worst part of it.
That is that, what he said,
if you want to go into this,
you want to see the true picture.
But that heightened my interest
rather than dumping it.
And I felt like, well,
this is something that
I was willing to do.
So he did encourage me along the way,
but there was no avenue
for going to psychiatry
and to make things a little
bit more interesting,
the head of surgery had
developed an interest in me.
And I suppose I was good with my hands
with surgical interest.
So you might admit to go into surgery
and I was going to have
full sponsorship to do that
and there was no avenue
for going to psychiatry.
And yet I felt like this is
what God was calling me to do.
So when the chief of surgery asked me,
invited me to come in to surgery,
I was forced to make a decision then.
I did write to him to say, no,
I'm not going to surgery.
I want to go into psychiatry.
And he reacted, like,
why would anyone choose
to go into psychiatry?
Especially since there was no clear path
for me to get there.
And there was a clear, easy
path for me to become a surgeon.
But yeah, I did talk to my uncle
and then it's a whole, long story.
But then the steps fell into place
and I did end up going into
psychiatric training at Duke,
where the young man who is
interviewing me went to school.
(laughs)
(speakers talking over each other)
That's another whole, long story.
- Full circle in many ways, so.
It's always, I mean,
I always feel like I learn more
each time I hear this story.
So it's also encouraging
to hear your willingness
to follow the passion
even though others weren't
necessarily supportive in that sense.
And then how did the sleep
part become integrated
into this story?
- Yes, in a sense, as I
was thinking about this,
it's the same kind of a story
in terms of the human interest,
the need to help others.
Like I said, I was in
(indistinct) medicine
and these ladies were
coming in and they had
psychiatric needs that
nobody was dealing with,
that nobody knew what to do about it.
It was in my first year
of training at Duke
that a patient came in and I
labeled him, the lazy farmer.
So this guy belonged to a farming family
and he was always sleepy and tired
and he would get out of the tractor
and his brothers would see him
out in the middle of the
field, sleeping on the tractor
and they said he was lazy.
I mean, he didn't like to
work like his brothers.
Then somebody said, well, maybe
he has some medical problem.
Maybe it was a seizure
problem or some other thing,
so he was brought to
Duke for a full workup.
And this was in the workup
that my professor then,
the professor who was training me in EEG.
I was in the psychiatric program,
but I was doing the EEG training,
which was combined with it.
And he said, maybe this
guy has sleep apnea,
maybe he's not lazy after all.
And that was the first I heard
of anything like sleep apnea.
To not make it a long
story, he did have a workup.
There were not established
sleep clinics then,
but he had workup, so that's
when he had treatment,
but that thing stuck in my mind.
This guy had a genuine
medical sleep problem.
It was labeled by family
and friends as lazy.
So the thought was how many
other so-called lazy farmers are
there who need help, who
nobody's giving the help to?
So that's what I'm saying,
maybe in the sense as
I was looking at this,
we have our own way of processing things.
So there's the rural people,
psychiatric patients in Ghana,
nobody was taking care of.
How many are there that needed help?
Then there's the lazy farmer.
How many more lazy farmers
are there who need help?
So again, the interest was
going to this thing, if you can,
to try and help people with that.
But it didn't mean that I
went directly into that.
I mean, I had an interest there,
but there was no avenue to follow it.
Again, this looks like
the same story before.
It was years after I had
left Duke that I was working
elsewhere where an old
professor from Duke came
to give grand rounds.
And he says, we want to
develop a sleep program.
I mean, he was at everything.
And I know your background
that you were combining
psychiatry and EEG things.
And I think you'd be an
ideal person to help us
get a program going.
So it was an invitation.
And then,
so I didn't realize that
this interest was known
to any others, but obviously
I've become known to others.
So then I did pick up where
I had left off, so to speak,
and that's how I came into sleep.
It's a long way to say
it, but I hope that.
- No, that's good and then it seems
like some of the passion was there,
but you didn't necessarily
have the opportunity initially
and then it still came
from an invitation later on
that you were able to take advantage of,
which seems really important.
It's also interesting
hearing the story because it,
in the sleep side, seems to parallel
a lot of what's happened with
mental health in this country
and globally, as people
have had better awareness
and try not to label
people as just, you know,
the aunt or uncle who's a
little bit off or this and that.
But with the same thing with sleep,
because the farmer was
just being labeled as lazy
without a true awareness of.
Do you think that's moved over the years
or are people still,
are there still things
people are unaware of
in terms of sleep and how
sleep problems can affect
our daily lives?
- I think it's improved a lot.
I mean a lot from, yeah,
even when I started out was
the early phases, about 30 years ago,
but when we moved to Grand Rapids,
the clinic maybe about 20 years ago,
and one of my colleagues,
there were three of us
that started by basic
training in psychiatry.
Then there was a neurologist
and then a pulmonologist.
And it's the pulmonologist
who had the hardest time
20 years ago.
A lot of his colleagues
were making statement.
I mean, you went to medical
school and you spent time
specializing in pulmonology,
and now you want to do sleep medicine?
It's like, you are giving up
all your medical training.
What is sleep medicine?
Why would you want to do that?
So there's a huge move from that.
So I think there's greater understanding
even compared to 20 years ago.
So it's good to see that.
- Yeah, that's really important.
What do you think about the understanding?
'Cause you talked about from
the medical perspective,
what about in the general public?
Do people have more of an awareness
or is there still this
lazy farmer attitude
that happens when people are struggling
with disturbed sleep?
- Yeah, I think in the general public
there's a greater awareness of this
and a greater understanding.
You still hear it, I mean as recently
as maybe two or three years ago,
I've had a parent call a
child with narcolepsy, lazy,
and it became a conflictual
situation where mother was
more accepting that there was a need
and all father would
think of no, he's lazy.
He's not like his brothers, if he were,
he would do such and such.
But again, it's moved,
so there is general
awareness has improved.
But it still needs to move forward.
This past week, I read
something that the NIH is giving
a three-year grant to the
Academy of Sleep Medicine to work
on increasing the
awareness of sleep apnea.
So there is a recognition,
there's a need to do more
public education on this.
- Yeah, and it seems
important just in terms
of every aspect of our lives
is how important sleep is.
So I'm also curious, just,
you know, for our listeners,
as well, what are some of the things
that you usually tell people
when people are trying
to understand what is,
'cause I've heard you use the
term sleep hygiene before.
What does good sleep hygiene look like?
And also, how do people know
if it's a sleep disturbance
that they're dealing with
or if it's something else
and how do they know when to get help?
- Yeah, sleep hygiene refers
to things that you can do
to promote your sleep, at first.
Maybe to backup on,
what are the important
components of sleep?
Okay, sometimes people will say,
what is the quality of my sleep?
If I sleep well, I have
good quality sleep.
Then it doesn't matter if it's
three hours or four hours,
but there are things
that we know about sleep.
Sleep duration is extremely important,
so, and we can talk about
this later, as well.
That sleep duration ignored,
regardless of quality,
if it's not adequate duration can lead
to major health problems.
So one of the things that we
need to know about sleep is
that we need to get enough of it
and we can't cheat with it.
It has consequences if
we do not get enough.
And then the other component
is sleep continuity.
It's preferable to get all
of our sleep in one block,
as much as possible.
When I've talked to medical groups,
well, especially when I
was in Ghana the last time.
And then young physicians will say, well,
I'm on call some of the time.
But what if I get two hours of sleep now,
and then I'm awake for the
next four hours and get another
two hours, and then I get an
hour and a half someplace?
Even if you have the same total duration,
if you get eight hours of sleep,
but it's broken up into
three or four pieces
with one or two-hour intervals,
as opposed to seven hours,
I'll use that as an example,
seven hours of continuous sleep.
Seven hours of more continuous
sleep is more refreshing
and has better health consequences
than a total of eight
hours of sleep broken up
into five or six segments.
So the duration is important
and getting consecutive hours
of sleep is important.
Then you ask about sleep hygiene,
they're suppressed to the
poor habits that can make
your sleep quality less than adequate.
So things like reading in bed,
especially if you are
reading on electronic device,
it will be a low-light intensity,
but that kind of thing can
still affect your sleep.
It can delay sleep onset.
Things like stimulants
or even drinking coffee
and drinking coffee in the
evening can affect you.
So those are the things
you want to guard against.
Keeping a regular sleep-wake
pattern is important.
And again, if it's irregular,
it will be more harmful than good.
But there is a component that
most people don't recognize,
which I think is important.
Some people will say go
to bed at the same time
and get up at the same time.
But the important thing is
to fix your wake-up time,
and the bedtime, in a sense,
will take care of itself
or the sleep onset.
It's easy to remember this
if you look at it this way,
you can make yourself wake up,
but you cannot make yourself fall asleep.
But what people sometimes do,
especially if they are
having some difficulty
with their sleep onset, will
say, if I get into bed at 10,
10 regularly, then I'll fall asleep by 11
or something like that.
But if you have problems falling asleep
and you get into bed
when you're not sleepy,
your level of anxiety can increase.
And the longer you're in
bed, the longer you get,
the more anxious you get,
and the more difficult
it becomes to sleep.
So fix your wake-up time and
try not to sleep too much
during the day.
We can talk about that later, too.
And then when it comes to nighttime,
your body will take care of that time.
So avoid stimulants at night,
maintaining good regular
rhythm for other things,
even including your meals, good,
regular exercise would help
and avoiding long periods
of sleep during the day.
These are some of the
components of sleep hygiene.
Sleep hygiene itself would not cure
a significant sleep problem.
But maintaining those
habits can be helpful.
- Those are all really, really good tips.
Do you ever get pushback from people?
'Cause I can imagine people say, oh,
but I have this and this and this to do,
or this job situation or this circumstance
and that's not feasible.
So what do I do if I can't get
all of those things in place?
What if I can't get a
consistent wake-up time or,
you know, family responsibilities
or infants at night?
That's a whole another topic.
But how do you help people
in those situations?
- Yeah, I think it's one
can use that same approach
you use for anything else.
In that area, somebody has diabetes,
so they have to watch
their diet and things.
But every so often a circumstance comes up
where they cannot follow that.
Yeah, so you can break from
that on a short-term basis,
but not on a long-term, consistent basis.
Yeah, so you are going through this.
Somebody has a baby.
Baby is waking up at night while there's,
you need to up to help your baby,
so there's not a whole
lot you can do about that.
But as soon as possible,
you want to get back to the good, ongoing,
consistent practices.
These are all things
that you want to be doing
on a long-term, ongoing basis.
And it's important to keep those in mind.
But when it comes to sleep hygiene,
even people who have
significant difficulties,
usually as soon as you
begin to mention it,
a lot of patients who say
no, I've done all of that
and it doesn't work,
but almost always, when you delve into it,
you can see that there's
a significant component
they are not following.
One big component is a daytime nap.
I often say there's a
good way to take a nap
and a not-so-good way to take a nap.
A good nap is one that is
more in the middle of the day,
where there's a natural dip
in the middle of the day.
A good nap is one that
is generally no more
than an hour long and
it's maybe a half-hour
to an hour would be sufficient.
But what some people do who
have significant problems is
they are following these things,
but then they don't get a good night
and then they more or less
crash, as they put it.
Then they will sleep for
four hours one afternoon
just to make it, but
that throws things off.
So the thing again, go
back to a regular rhythm
and follow the guidelines for a nap.
Don't go for days without adequate sleep
and then sleep for four or five hours
during the day on some day.
- That's really helpful.
- Consistency is important.
- Yeah and it's the way
you're sharing the story
that seems like a lot of
times people are just using
their own best educated guess
to try and address things,
but that might not necessarily be
what's best for the situation.
- Exactly, exactly.
- So that's helpful to hear.
I'm sure people are,
I imagine people are taking
notes or even thinking
about ways to apply these pieces, as well.
I was also just gonna ask about insomnia,
just because anecdotally,
just talking to people,
there are so many people that
say they have problems falling
asleep at certain times of their lives.
Are those rates changing over time
or are people just more aware
of those sleep disturbances?
- Yeah, I would say people are more aware
because the studies showed
that about 10% of people have
significant insomnia and
this is longstanding.
And 10% is a big number.
That has been more or less terrible.
And then when we talk about insomnia,
many would tend to focus on
the difficulty falling asleep
in the first place, but by definition,
that's not all there is.
Some may fall asleep easily,
but have difficulty maintaining sleep.
So difficulty maintaining
sleep is also a problem.
Or there are those that wake up too early
and that is insomnia, too.
It's important in the definition, though,
to add the third component.
It's not just difficulty
falling off to sleep
or maintaining sleep, but it's associated
with some impairment
in daytime functioning.
That is important because it's,
during my training in sleep medicine,
this lady came in and
she was quite distressed
because she had insomnia.
So then we asked the question,
so do you have difficulty
falling off to sleep?
She says, no.
Do you have difficulty staying asleep?
When you wake up in the
morning, do you feel refreshed?
She says, yes,
but I'm getting about six
and a half hours of sleep.
Six to seven, I think.
But everybody in my family
sleeps about eight to nine hours.
So I have insomnia because
I have fewer hours of sleep.
But the hours is not everything.
So insomnia means you have
difficulty falling asleep
or maintaining sleep and you also have
some daytime consequence to it.
So if you are sleeping fewer hours
than the rest of the family,
but you feel perfectly fine,
you feel perfectly refreshed,
then by definition,
you do not have insomnia.
- Oh, okay.
- So I think it's important.
It's not the number, it's
the things that go with it.
And I think maybe I deviated
from what your question was,
but.
- Yeah, that's helpful, as well,
because I know just talking with people,
people from different families
that said, oh, you know,
well, some people in my family
sleep four or five hours
and they went in for all
the sleep studies to see
is there something?
But they said they've
been functioning fine.
And so eventually they were
just told that that was
how they operate.
But then, you know, they
interact with others
and people think, oh,
what's wrong with you?
Why are you only sleeping
four hours a night?
That can't be healthy.
So what you shared is definitely helpful
for that perspective, as well.
- Yes.
But it's also important
to add that there are some
who claim that all they need
is four or five hours of sleep.
The thing is that, we said the
general rule is most people,
the academy stands by this,
seven to nine hours of
sleep is adequate sleep.
Other studies show that
when you're more or less
consistently getting less
than six hours of sleep,
there can be major consequences.
And this includes consequences
by daytime sleepiness
or tiredness.
There can be cognitive impairment.
You are not as sharp as you should be.
And sometimes people do not recognize it.
And sometimes I'll say if
somebody is an A student
or A-plus student and is
performing at a B-plus level,
I mean, it's not, people
will say that's acceptable.
But if you are an A-plus
person functioning
at B-plus level,
you're actually not
functioning at your peak
and you don't recognize it.
So things like generally less
than six hours of sleep can be
an impairment.
Your risk of cardiovascular
consequences is higher.
Your immunity level is high,
studies have been done.
There's one that struck
me, came out recently.
Just a common cold
and people who were sleeping
less than six hours of sleep,
didn't ask them to change anything,
just selected groups and
those who are getting
adequate sleep, seven to nine hours.
Those sleeping less than six
hours of sleep generally,
and they are healthy.
When the two groups are exposed
to the common cold virus,
those who sleep less than
six hours have a fourfold
increased risk of getting the cold,
as opposed to those who sleep adequately.
I see that as important
these days of COVID,
nobody has studied that.
But if you are sleeping consistently less,
are you a greater risk of getting COVID?
We don't know that, but
we know that people have
a high risk, like I said, of heart attack,
they have a high risk of developing
other medical consequences.
So we should take insomnia seriously,
it does have consequences.
We are talking about mental health-wise,
so my background is mental health, too.
We know that those with longstanding,
long-term insomnia have a greater risk
of developing depression
or having anxiety problems.
Those with depression are
more likely to have insomnia,
but those with insomnia also more likely
to develop depression.
And sometimes people feel like
insomnia is just my problem,
or I can just deal with it on my own,
but there are times that it
does need to be looked at
professionally and managed.
Long answers to short questions.
- All very good and very helpful.
And I'm sure, again, I'm
sure that this is something
that's very,
that people are just thinking
about because I'm sure
in people's own lives or in
people they interact with,
there are lots of things
they may have noticed
that they've never
really heard talked about
as fully before.
So it's really helpful
to have that, as well.
And it makes me think about what you said
about the public conversations
and the emphasis on that
in the next few years,
I think that's very important, as well.
And I was thinking about
what you were saying
about people operating at lower level
that might not be their peak performance.
How do you help people realize that?
Because if someone has been in that,
when someone's been operating
at a B plus for 10 years
and that's the norm, do
you leave it that way?
Do you help them try and adjust
to improve their quality of life?
Or how does that conversation get started?
- Yeah, it's difficult to convince people
when they don't see the
evidence on their own.
So we talk about insomnia,
I'll shift to something else.
The lazy farmer had sleep apnea.
So I'll talk a little bit about
sleep apnea at this point.
Sleep apnea is when you see
some of the most dramatic
changes and addresses this
question about functioning
at a B-plus level,
instead of A-plus level.
You see somebody who comes
in, they have loud snoring.
They have some tiredness and
sleepiness during the day.
Often this is coming out in men.
So the man comes in, not because
he thinks he has a problem,
but because he's tired
of his wife complaining
that he's snoring so loudly
she is not getting good enough sleep.
He comes in, he has a sleep study.
A diagnosis of sleep apnea is made.
He gets active treatment for that.
One of the most common treatments
is the C-PAP continuous
positive pressure device that he wears.
And it's maybe surprising
or amazing, or maybe not,
but people will come back and they say,
I should have done this 10 years ago
because all this time, so
I thought it's just my age
that because now I'm 45 or 50
that's why I've not been as sharp.
But you treated sleep
apnea and this goes away.
So that's when they recognize
that it's extremely difficult
to convince people they are
functioning at a lower level
'til they see it themselves.
So the goal is not so
much to convince them
that they will function at
a higher level, but to say,
this we know is a problem.
This is a medical condition.
Or if it's insomnia, if it's sleep apnea.
So let's treat it and see what happens.
And I often offer people,
let's give it a try,
let's see what happens.
Another thought comes to mind.
I say, I love to be proven wrong
in terms of (speaker drowned out).
So a lady comes in,
she's averaging about
20 cups of coffee a day.
And she says she has
insomnia and she needs help.
And I said, well, you talk
about her sleep hygiene.
One of the first things
you can do is to try
and cut back down on how much coffee
you are drinking per day.
And she wasn't convinced it
would make any difference.
But these were own
words when she came back
for her first follow up.
She says, I decided to do
this to prove you wrong.
I was sure it wasn't going
to make any difference,
but I thought, okay, I'll just cut back,
I cut back to half my consumption
and I'll go back to this doctor
and I'll show you how wrong it is.
She comes back and she's surprised.
She's surprised (speaker
drowned out by laughing).
So this is why I said, no,
it's great to be proven wrong
on this, okay, (indistinct).
So then there is, going
back to sleep apnea.
I see a 70-year-old guy, he's about 70
and sleep apnea can
present in unusual ways.
For some men of (microphone cuts out),
it can cause you to go
to the bathroom a lot,
four, five, six times at night.
And this was this patient's major problem.
So he goes to see a urologist
and the urologist says,
no, your prostate is fine.
In spite of your age, we don't
need to do anything there.
He comes to the sleep
clinic and he's upset.
And he says, my doctor is a good doctor,
which is why I followed
through, but I think he's wrong.
What does waking up a lot to
go to the bathroom at night
have to do with sleep?
It's my waking up that
is disturbing my sleep.
He should fix that, then I'll be fine.
But he says I should be at
the sleep clinic, so I'm here.
Or in the way you put
it, I know it's my age
and it's my prostate.
I can't do anything about my age.
If you fix the prostate, I'll be fine.
Anyway, he goes through the sleep study,
he has confirmed sleep apnea.
He gets treated.
He comes back for his first follow up,
that's about six weeks later.
And he's saying, strange
thing that happened.
He forgot some of our discussion.
Now I wake up only once
to go to the bathroom.
So then I asked him,
did the urologist decide
to do your prostate?
He says, no.
And then I asked him,
well maybe (indistinct).
So I said, are you still 70 years old?
And he looked at me like,
what is he talking about?
I said, you told me it was
your age and your prostate.
Your prostate is still
there and you are still 70.
(laughs)
So it was a long way
to answer this question
that you cannot really convince people
until after they've had the treatment.
So the goal is to try
somehow to get them to agree
to the treatment.
And often we'll phrase
it that this is a test.
Let's do it.
You don't lose anything.
About the worst is you lose
a co-pay for the workup
and the test.
And if you prove me wrong, that's fine.
But yeah, so.
- Well, it's interesting because
it sounds like you're using
some of the psychological
tools, as well, to get people
to go through it and experience it
and then see the outcome.
But it sounds like it's so,
I mean, it's so transformative
in a lot of ways.
But I guess the other question is,
'cause as you were
talking, it seems that also
within the medical community,
people have to be aware.
So the fact that the urologist
actually sent the patient
to the sleep clinic was also important.
Do you think that's
something that's uniform
across the board or is there,
are there disparities that
come up in terms of the access
to care that people have
and whether people are cognizant of that?
And I mentioned that just
because of some of the things
that we talk about in terms of, you know,
some of this systems in place in the US
and how that impacts different communities
and communities of color, in particular,
and whether there's equal
access to these services,
especially around sleep.
Because as you mentioned,
it has so many impacts on so
many aspects of our health,
just our physical health
and our mental health.
- Yeah, a couple of things.
In terms of referrals,
unfortunately there are
still healthcare providers
who are not paying enough
attention to sleep issues.
I mean the clinics that
I've done in the past
and even in my current position,
you often will see the same kinds of names
or certain primary physicians have
a lot of referrals coming through
and some have almost none.
So obviously people with
sleep problems are not
pre-selecting who they would see.
So that would mean that
there are some clinicians
who are not paying enough
attention to send the patients.
Access is a huge problem.
Actually, I was looking
at something this week,
the morbidity and mortality
weekly report from the CDC.
The one from September 24th,
so this, yeah, this past week.
It was looking at sleep in children
four months old to 17 years.
So children and adolescents,
and it said about a third in that group,
a third are not getting the
adequate duration of sleep
that they need and there
are regional differences.
It's about 25% in Maine,
about 49% in Mississippi.
And when you look at this, and say,
we do know that inadequate
sleep has health consequences,
but you see greater risk
or higher prevalence
in racial and ethnic minorities.
And then in areas where the socioeconomic,
people are at the bottom or the lower end
of the socioeconomic climate.
So these groups have higher
prevalence rates of almost all
sleep disturbances and they
have lower rates of access.
There's another thing that
makes that even more distressing
is this,
when it comes to the
things like sleep apnea,
if you've had the same level,
the consequences are often
worse, racial minorities.
So there are ethnic
and racial differences.
So if you have, for example,
a Caucasian with a certain
degree of sleep apnea,
and there's a black person
who has the same degree
of sleep apnea, the chances
that the black person,
even with the same access will
get more health consequences
are higher.
So yeah, so it's not equal.
And the Academy of Sleep
Medicine right now is trying
to pay attention to that,
to the racial, ethnic,
and socioeconomic disparity
in the distribution
and the availability
of access to treatment
for these groups.
- Yeah, that seems very important,
especially because of the
way that you phrased for all.
'Cause that seems like it will
affect all aspects of health
for the individual's life.
And so that just in
addition to everything else
that has been discussed,
obviously around health disparities,
it seems like sleep is
a huge part of that,
which I don't hear talked about as much.
And maybe that's just
the circles that I'm in,
but even in public discourse,
it doesn't seem that that's
often brought to the forefront,
but it sounds like hopefully
there are pushes to make sure
that becomes a better
part of understanding.
- Yes, like I said,
the Academy of Sleep
Medicine is working on it.
Yeah, but within the
general medical field,
maybe we are not getting
enough attention on it.
It's more recently, the
Academy's pushing the whole area,
the disparity in the distribution.
So
first of all,
in some of the groups, the
lower socioeconomic groups,
people may not recognize that
there is a problem with sleep
and maybe physicians or care
providers in those places,
I know recognize it enough to
encourage the people to go.
But then part of, increase
the level of awareness
in primary care physicians
so they will recognize this
and treat it because some
people are very far away
from any center, any established
sleep disorder centers.
But the thing is to get
primary care physicians
to recognize the importance
and to address it
because there are many, many things
that primary care
providers can do to help.
- I'm curious if you ever
see any resistance to that,
because you talked about
some of the patients
that are resistant to it and
don't realize there's an issue
until they've tried to prove
you wrong and they've seen it.
Does that ever happen with
the primary physicians
in certain communities
or even in the community?
Because I'm thinking also about stigma,
whether there's stigmas
that are still coming
into play, as well.
I know I asked several
questions at once, but. (laughs)
- Yeah, no, but it's
probably more difficult to,
with the primary care
physicians because it's,
for as long as we've done
this in the community
in which I am now, there are still
some primary care physicians
who almost never refer a patient.
So, and the knowledge is there,
you do educational programs
and they attend these things,
but maybe like everything else,
because obviously a physician,
even when they've had patients
who have been treated,
it looked like for some reason,
some are still not convinced
and they still wouldn't send patient.
So in a sense, it's easier
to convert, so to speak,
the patient who has had
a positive experience
then physician who does
not recognize this.
- Yeah, that's a really good point.
So people who are able to just share that
in their communities, as well.
Have you seen that happen in
some ways or in some places,
either here or in Ghana?
Have you seen those who've actually gone
through the experience as patients,
have you seen them have
impact in the communities,
either in the states or in Ghana?
- Yes, they have actually.
When I started here in Grand Rapids,
that one of my colleagues used to say,
he's a pulmonary physician
whose friends were thinking
he was leaving medicine
by going into sleep.
But then he always would encourage you,
said our best promoters
for the sleep clinic are the patients.
So you treat a patient well.
And I do have a lot of patients who tell
their family members and friends
and colleagues to come in
and the physician sometimes
becomes secondary.
They will get a good
treatment and they will tell
their physician that, well,
this is what I realized I have,
my cousin needs to go, too.
So can you refer my cousin
to the sleep clinic?
So sometimes there is the
patient who drives it.
Yeah, so the patients drive
this in a lot of ways.
Not so much in Ghana, and
now I've started a relation
with Nigeria.
I recently learned,
you can leave your country
and forget the culture.
In that culture, you don't talk
about your health problems.
So that I've seen patients,
and actually this last week,
that somebody actually told me,
I'm not going to let anyone know.
So they got a patient,
even when they've had
a positive response,
I don't got to share that
information with anyone else.
So yes, patients drive the
growth of the clinic here,
but in a different
culture that doesn't work.
So then you have to work
through the primary physicians.
Like we said again, that role
of authority in that context.
So it going to be more
important in that context
to convince the physicians
to send patients.
Or I see the patients can refer themselves
or convince their doctors to send them.
- Well, it seems a lot just being aware of
just the culture within, like
you said, that it's operating
and the system's in place.
- Yeah, yeah.
Very much so.
And obviously when it comes to sleep,
there are various sleep disorders.
I think you had a question
of when does one treat it
on their own and when do you
seek help from a professional?
A lot of people with insomnia will try
and manage on their own, but,
and there's habits and
there are behavioral things
you can do to improve things.
We talk about their sleep
hygiene and there are more
specific things,
but even we've done all of
these, the usual things,
you know, and they are not working,
it's important then to
seek professional help
because of the consequences
of untreated insomnia
or excessive sleepiness.
Sleep apnea and some of
the conditions that cause
excessive sleepiness can be
dangerous because people can get
to the point of falling asleep driving,
which puts the person at risk
and puts others on the road
at risk, as well.
So that's an insomnia thing,
if it's not improving.
You should avoid taking sleeping
pills on a long-term basis.
A sleeping pill may have a
place in managing short-term
insomnia problems, but if you are taking
whatever you are taking, if
you see the dose going up,
the dose keeps climbing
and the effectiveness is decreasing.
That may be one indication to see someone.
For those who have problem with snoring
and begin to develop daytime sleepiness,
the snoring itself may not
necessarily mean you have
a sleep apnea or major sleep problem.
But if there is disruption of your sleep,
you don't feel as refreshed
when you wake up in the morning,
or you are beginning to have
some daytime sleepiness,
or in terms of the sleep apnea,
if whoever is sleeping with
you or anyone who has observed
you sleeping comments that it looks
like your breathing gets
interrupted at night,
then you want to seek
professional help for that
because that's when you would
need a sleep study to clarify
what is going on.
Again, it's because of the consequences,
risk of getting a stroke is higher,
risk of getting a heart attack is higher.
The cognitive impairment
can come on slowly,
but it can be significant.
Again, this is one of those
things that people will recover
and go back to work.
We relate this to faith, as well.
So then the example of
a pastor comes to mind
who has sleep apnea and
didn't recognize it.
Things were not prominent,
but it was after he got
treated that he said,
so this is why I was getting
to the point I was having
difficulty preparing my sermons.
I mean, certainly I work
on it and then I'm standing
at the pulpit and my
things were not clicking.
And I thought, well,
there's a spiritual thing,
I'm not praying enough and things.
Well his sleep apnea was not treated,
so his brain was not
functioning adequately.
So when things are not
improving that you've tried
on your own, then it's
time to see a professional
to see what's going on.
- Those are really helpful,
really helpful tips, as well.
And I'm sure again, that
people, this is gonna,
these are things that people
are going to be thinking.
Like you said, someone who said,
I wish I had known this 10 years earlier
and those types of things.
So, I appreciate you sharing those.
I'm also curious though,
because you talked about how
sleep affects overall health
and then how it affects mental health.
And then if people have a
higher prevalence for depression
or anxiety because of sleep disturbances
or the other way around.
How do you advise people
what to tackle first?
So, I mean, if they're
noticing that they're having
some challenges with anxiety,
but also having challenges with sleep.
Where should people go
to try and address that?
Are there parts they should
try and do their own?
Do they have to go,
because there's also the challenge of,
well, how many different
providers do they have to go to,
to deal with the intersections?
- Yeah.
I think it's, as a general
rule, is always good to start
with your primary care provider
and whether it's anxiety
or the sleep thing.
Anxiety can be so disabling,
anxiety and the depression.
And I say that it will
make sense to approach
the anxiety or depression initially.
From the standpoint of both
counselings kinds of treatment,
as well as medication kinds of treatment,
you would expect that.
And I think most of it,
the primary provider who
addresses the depression
and anxiety, if they are using counselor
or the psychologist, will
give input that will probably
impact positively on their sleep, as well.
But when it comes to
medication management, many,
I was going to say most,
but that's in the past,
things have changed.
But still many antidepressant
medications and medications
for anxiety have an effect
on promoting sleep, as well.
So the single agent can
address both the depression
and the sleep, so that
is a place to start.
But if the depression
and anxiety are improving
and the sleep is still
not improving enough,
then you may consider
going to a sleep clinic.
But if the major problem
is something like snoring
or the sleep is so extreme
that somebody cannot function
during the day.
And a lot of patients will
be able to identify which is
more prominent.
When their sleep is more
disabling, it's more significant.
It may not be critical
where you start from.
Most sleep clinicians are
aware of the depression
and anxiety component of things.
So when you see them and they say,
well, this is not so much the sleep,
it's more the anxiety and depression.
There's an interesting thing here.
The stigma about mental
illness is decreasing,
but it's still there.
And there are many people who prefer to go
to the sleep clinic first
not because that's the most part,
but that's more acceptable.
A sleep problem, it's funny the way.
A sleep problem is a
medical, biological problem.
But as mental illness
problem is non-medical,
it's your mind is doing something
and that's not as
acceptable to most people.
And again, in the faith
community, there has been.
Again, it's proving that if you have
a mental health problem,
then it's a lack of faith
or it's your poor decision-making
or it's your poor choices.
That's what is causing it.
That may not necessarily be solved.
But as I was thinking about this,
it doesn't mean that it's your fault.
Although you may have
something to do with it.
In the same way that
somebody's eating habits
and their lifestyle may promote
their risk of developing
diabetes, type two diabetes.
So somebody's poor choices
and poor habits may lead
to a sleep problem or a
mental health problem.
But on the other hand,
there can be somebody
who develops type one diabetes.
The childhood who develops
childhood diabetes,
they have done all the right things.
There are some things we inherit.
So we should look at both the same way.
You can develop diabetes,
even when you've done
all the right things,
but you can develop diabetes
because you have done some wrong thing.
So in the mental health arena,
there's no reason we should
look at it any differently.
You can develop a sleep
problem when you've done
all the right things,
but can also develop a sleep problem
because you haven't done the right thing.
So it's important to pay attention to that
because I think we run the risk sometimes
of excusing people,
because we want to look at the biological.
No, it has nothing to
do with what you did,
it's all just biological.
It's the holistic idea of things.
And again, you asked me this,
you ask it the whole thing
about where does faith come in.
God made us one.
We have the physical
component of ourselves,
our emotional component,
our spiritual component.
And we like to separate
the different parts of it.
It should be all one whole thing.
And in all of these areas,
it may be pre-determined
or nothing we did wrong.
That is all the areas,
in all of the areas,
it may be something we need to do right.
Because I think sometimes
we excuse people,
no, you didn't do anything wrong.
Well, maybe wrong is not the right term,
but no, you have some responsibility.
There are some things you
probably didn't do as well
and some things you can
improve to change things.
So I shouldn't go on, then
I'll become like I'm preaching.
(laughs)
- But that was so well said.
I mean, just all the different components
that you've brought in together,
especially about the holistic
approach to these things.
So I think it's not easy,
but important for us
to continue to wrestle through.
And of course, even as you were talking,
I'm seeing where some of my
own influences in thinking
came from because you could
be hosting this podcast
with those themes and just all the things
(microphone cuts out) incorporate.
So it's a good reminder to
me, also, of the example
that you've set in your profession
and how that is something
that I've been able
to also carry out from
you without even realizing
how much of that actually
might've originated
with you or those that
influenced you, as well.
So, I mean, I think it's very well said
and just all the different
components that we have
to think about versus just
trying to put things in one box
or another,
because they're all interplaying.
I mean, even as you were
talking that people were saying,
well, this is because of
your own poor decision-making
that you have this health
ailment or this sleep issue.
But then you also said
that the sleep can lead
to poor decision making.
So it seems like those
two can't be divorced
and it's really important to help people.
Have you seen, as a closing question,
have you seen us as a society
get better about moving
towards what you just stated
for that holistic approach?
Or are there, I mean,
clearly there's still ways
we need to grow in that,
but have you seen it
shifting or are we still far
from where we need to be here?
- Yes.
No, I think there's a
definite shift, okay.
And you are an example of that.
Okay, so the one way (indistinct)
Duke when we started doing
faith and health, it was on the side.
It wasn't part of the program.
And there was a lot of resistance to that.
I mean it's 30 years ago,
I mean, 40 years ago,
no university would be
hosting this. (laughs)
No university would
want it's name attached
to what we are doing now.
So it's moved, it's moved a
lot and it's good to see that.
Yeah, so.
I mean, we still have ways
to go and there are still
areas to develop.
But no, as I look at you,
I see where your influences come from.
But as I'm looking at you doing this,
I feel like where you are
doing so much greater work
than I ever did and I don't
see myself doing a whole lot.
So, we are very thankful.
No, but we've made progress
and I think we'll continue
to make progress.
And it's more open and
it's more the forum,
the things you've done with
the Town Hall meetings.
Again, these were done
on a small-scale basis.
So we are way ahead of where
we were 20, 30 years ago,
and even 10 years ago, so
we are making progress.
But we shouldn't just stop now
(indistinct) we've achieved our goal.
As Paul says, we keep
striving for the goal
and we are not there yet.
And so long as we live,
we need to keep striving
to reach higher levels.
- Well, I'm grateful to be
able to play a part in that,
as well, and to carry the legacy on.
And it's helpful just to have
that context reminder to know
even just what we're doing now
and how much growth we've had
as a society and as
universities to be able to have
those types of intersecting conversations.
And to really think about
ourselves as whole people.
So I'm (speakers talking
over each other) continue.
- So I hope some of the things
I've said will be helpful
to some people.
But if it's only one person I
said, it's, I mean in a sense,
I went into mental health
for one or two people.
I went to sleep medicine for one person.
So yeah, if one person benefits from this,
I suppose it's good (microphone cuts out).
- Yep, and I know that many, many have,
and I think that will continue, as well.
So thank you so much for
joining the Addy Hour,
your namesake podcast
in the sense. (laughs)
So I'm grateful and I know
this is definitely gonna bless
a lot of people,
something that's been gratifying for me.
And I always learn more every time I talk
through these things with you,
as surprising as that may seem to some.
- Thank you.
- Great having you on the Addy Hour
and I hope that you all
enjoyed this episode
and share it widely because I think
there's so many important things here
that people will benefit from, as well.
Until next time.
(theme song music)